they had a reputation for being really
great about renegotiations past season
three or something like that where they
started really paying well and they had
a really great reputation for that we
were on the cusp of that but there was a
strange snafu that happened on our show
that caused nafu a bizarre snowfood
basically we were getting ready to to
shoot season four and five back to back
because they liked the numbers I mean
that my objection was guys if you if you
keep promoting the show you can grow the
audience even bigger because we're we're
delivering I think a really good show
they were busy trying to make other
shows and they actually again I had some
people admit to me like yes part of uh
the large part of your publicity budget
is actually going to the budget of that
show and I'm like that's great terrific
which caused me to that's what it always
is we were just talking about Tom and I
about Smallville it was such a success
but they're like yeah but all our other
shows are bombing so we need to take the
money from smallville's earnings